Jordan Peele's follow-up to his masterly debut
Get Out is a terrifying plunge into the double
depths of humanity.
And hidden in the movie's opening scenes and
throughout the film are a stack of clues that
cleverly reveal its dramatic twist ending.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and today
I'm really excited to peel back and break
down for you the many layers of the horrifying
and thrilling film Us.
We've got tons of easter eggs you may have
missed and hidden secrets to examine; and
there will, of course, be spoilers, so take
care if you haven't seen it yet.
Let's quickly review what happened at the
end of Us so we understand exactly how all
the clues in the movie foreshadow and explain
the final twist.
The Tethered were originally created as part
of an experiment to control their above-ground
counterparts.
When that failed, the doubles were abandoned
in their underground world of tunnels.
But Red, Adelaide's double, helps the Tethered
rise up against the above-ground people, killing
many of them and forming a human chain across
the land.
However, the twist we discover is that the
Tethered's leader Red is actually the original
Adelaide.
In the 1980s fairground scene, young Adelaide
encountered her double in a hall of mirrors.
Adelaide's double overpowered her and took
Adelaide's place with her parents above ground.
In the final showdown, present-day Adelaide
kills Red burying underground forever the
truth about who she really is, or at least
that's what she thinks.
Because her son Jason was also in the tunnels
when Red revealed that present-day Adelaide
was originally one of the Tethered, and it
seems like he may have overheard her secret.
Which is why he gives her a sort of strange
look and pulls down his mask as they drive
off in the final scene.
So, now we've got the ending covered, let's
jump back to the movie's opening scenes where
Jordan Peele laid clues for everything in
the ending and the twist.
The movie starts with Young Adelaide watching
a Hands Across America commercial, which is
full of imagery and themes we'll see repeated
during the film.
The idea of doubles and twins is immediately
brought up with the mention of 6 million people
and 12 million eyes, the Twin Towers, the
repeated letter Gs of the Golden Gate bridge,
and the words 'from sea to shining sea' accompany
an image of a lighthouse which appears twice,
once on the left of the screen and then immediately
flipped with a mirror image to the right;
and to cap it all, after the promo ends, we
see a copy of Young Adelaide reflected in
the TV screen, sitting next to a white rabbit
toy.
Now, that's intriguing because the advert
is a huge clue to the real identity of the
Tethered's leader.
When Young Adelaide is switched with her tethered
counterpart, her tethered double steals her
Michael Jackson Thriller T-shirt and leaves
her only with her Hands Across America T-shirt.
Over the years she spent growing up underground,
Adelaide, who we now call Red, found inspiration
in memories from her previous life above ground.
Her memory of that 1986 Hands Across America
charity event during which millions of Americans
formed a human chain across parts of the country
to raise money for the homeless is something
that's been seared into her brain.
And so Red takes inspiration from that to
organise an act of rebellion where the Tethered
send a bloody message by rising up, killing
their above-ground counterparts, and recreating
that human chain from Hands Across America.
The clothes worn by the Tethered give their
group the feeling of a cult or escaped prisoners,
which in a way they are.
And Red, who designed these outfits, took
inspiration from several classic horror and
cultural icons from the time prior to 1986
when she was still above ground.
The red work-wear jumpsuits and the single
gloves worn by the doppelgangers are a nod
to Michael Jackson's Thriller video as well
as his custom of donning a glove on just one
hand.
Their outfits also evoke Michael Myers' overalls
in the Halloween movies.
And, likewise, their gloves are a shout-out
to Freddie Krueger's look in the Nightmare
on Elm Street series, a VHS tape of which
you see by the TV set at the start of Peele's
film, which is doubly fitting as it's one
of the director's favourite horrors.
Another of those VHS tapes by the TV is the
mid-80s horror film C.H.U.D., which hints
nicely at how Us will end because as well
as featuring monsters living beneath the streets
who eventually emerge above ground, C.H.U.D.
also includes a government cover-up and, interestingly
for Peele's movie, people who go missing.
By the way, the idea of conspiracies also
pops up early on in Us when Zora says that
the government uses fluoride in water to control
people's minds.
Not only is this a pointer to the failed experiment
revealed at the end of the movie, but it may
also be a little shout-out to the movie Dr
Strangelove, especially given Jordan Peele's
love of Stanley Kubrick films like The Shining.
Another key detail to understand the film's
ending is the constant repetition of the number
11.
In the very first scene, there's the news
and weather promo, "all on 7 at 11".
There's the prize young Adelaide choses at
the fairground, "I want number 11", she tells
her dad.
There's the alarm clock that hits 11 minutes
past 11 shortly before the Wilsons' doubles
turn up and wreak havoc.
And those same numbers are on the roof of
the ambulance as it drives away at the end.
And, importantly, a man with a "Jeremiah 11:11"
sign pops up by the beach in the past and
the present.
The man with the sign is a harbinger of doom,
as you can tell from his Biblical verse: "Therefore
this is what the Lord says: 'I will bring
on them a disaster they cannot escape.
Although they cry out to me, I will not listen
to them."
This Biblical warning precedes Adelaide's
traumatic experiences in both the past and
the present.
What's intriguing for this movie though is
that this particular chapter of the Bible
is all about how God's people have forgotten
their own history, where they come from, and
the commitment and promises they made to get
to where they are.
All of which ties in nicely with the way Adelaide
tries to bury the memory of what happened
in 1986 as she wants to forget how she ended
up where she is today.
In other words, she's desperately trying to
avoid confronting the fact that she's a doppelganger
who used violence to replace the original
Adelaide and now she's terrified what consequences
her actions back then might have for herself
and her family today if she returns to the
scene of her original crime.
The film's frequently repeated Bible quote
is a stark message that goes out to its protagonists
and viewers in general, and also, given the
double meaning of the film's title, specifically
to the US.
When Gabe asks his family's doppelgangers,
"What are you people?", the question word
"what" implies a certain dehumanisation as
Gabe doesn't quite see the doubles as human
beings.
Red's answer, "We're Americans", is unnerving
for the Wilsons who see the strange but familiar
beings in front of them as different, not
equal to themselves.
As a visual double of the number 1, the number
11 perfectly suits the film's imagery and
themes of doubling, mirroring, and repetition.
But through the ages, the number 11 has also
acquired some interesting symbolism as it
can signify "transition, excess, peril and
conflict", all of which there's plenty of
in this film.
And it can also symbolise "sin and repentance",
which seems very fitting given this movie
suggests we need to take a long, hard look
at ourselves to find the source of our individual
and collective problems rather than constantly
be rushing to blame other people or groups
for our self-inflicted disasters.
That is, we are our own worst enemies.
The owl that pops out and frightens Young
Adelaide at the fair fits in with the murals
of trees and wildlife around her.
But given the setting is a Vision Quest, with
a sign to 'Find Yourself', the bird's symbolism
is also interesting for the film.
In some symbolism, owls are connected to magical
forces and the idea of being able to see beyond
your immediate reality, something the film
seems to implore us to do.
And it's also intriguing that, symbolically,
owls embody the duality seen in the film as
they can be considered a good or a bad omen,
depending on what happens next.
Clearly, for young Adelaide, it was a bad
omen, though things worked out better for
her doppelganger who got to experience life
above ground.
Inside the hall of mirrors, Young Adelaide
starts whistling the tune to the nursery rhyme
Itsy Bitsy Spider, but then her clone takes
over, whistling it too.
The nursery rhyme is about a spider climbing
up a drainpipe before being flushed down again
when it rains.
And then when the sun comes out and dries
away the rain, the spider is able to finally
emerge from below.
The lyrics match exactly how young Adelaide's
clone comes up to the surface, then drags
Adelaide back down below, before returning
to the surface to take young Adelaide's place
in the world above ground.
Years later Red finally has her moment and
comes up to the surface for the Untethering.
And that final emergence from below by Red
is foreshadowed in the scene at the holiday
home where present-day Adelaide spots a tiny
little spider creeping out from below a bigger
toy spider on the coffee table.
The cages of rabbits gradually revealed during
the film's opening credits are another fascinating
detail that point to the film's final twist.
Peele moves quickly from an image of young
Adelaide's horrified face at seeing her double
for the first time and cuts straight to a
close-up of a caged rabbit's face, indicating
young Adelaide's ultimate fate of being caged
underground with the Tethered, who, like rabbits,
have been living in tunnels and were used
for experiments.
The flashback to Young Adelaide and her parents
at the doctors after her traumatic hall of
mirrors experience is another vital clue to
the film's body swap twist.
Two details are particularly crucial: first,
Adelaide has been acting differently to her
usual self and she doesn't speak.
And secondly, there's her mother's words:
'I just want my little girl back.'
A few scenes later we learn that the Wilson
family's doubles do not speak, which explains
why young Adelaide couldn't speak after the
funfair.
And the fact that only present-day Adelaide's
doppelganger can speak but sounds like someone
who hasn't used her vocal chords in an extremely
long time is further evidence of the hall
of mirrors body swap.
Young Adelaide's mum didn't realise, but she
never did get her 'little girl back' as the
child living with her after that day in Santa
Cruz was actually her daughter's clone.
This hint is echoed in the present day when
Adelaide tries to tell her husband Gabe why
she feels so uncomfortable on holiday, 'I
don't feel like myself', she says; but just
like Young Adelaide's parents, Gabe doesn't
know or understand what that really means,
and replies, 'I think you look like yourself.'
Then there's the way, later during the home
invasion, that Red orders Adelaide, 'tether
yourself to the table', an act which mirrors
how Young Adelaide's doppelanger chained her
to the bed in the underground tunnels before
leaving her there and replacing her above
ground.
Of course, there are other signs that things
are not all they appear to be.
For example, in the background here, there's
the board game 'Guess Who?', and notice that
other game, 'Magic', is actually turned upside-down,
much like Adelaide's life has been since the
hall of mirrors encounter with her double.
Peele's film begins by showing us how we like
to think of ourselves – the good Samaritans
of the Hands Across America promo – and
ends by exposing our shadowy side which we
so often prefer to keep hidden both from ourselves
and the rest of the world.
Essentially, Us is a film about society's
hypocrisy, the everyday violence of our privileges
and power, as well as issues such as class,
race, xenophobia, and general fear of the
other, as well as the way so many choose to
ignore the ties that bind us and look instead
to sow seeds of division, keeping others down
in order to raise themselves up, in a constant
game of Whac-a-mole, a game we see Young Adelaide's
dad playing as she wanders off, soon to be
lost to her parents forever.
Now, did you catch any other details in Us?
And do you have any theories about the ending?
Let me know in the comments below!
Coming up I'll have new videos on Pet Sematary
and Chilling Adventures of Sabrina, so if
you enjoy deep-dives into your favourite horrors,
be sure to subscribe and hit the bell to get
all my new videos.
Tap left for my theory on how Us and Get Out
are connected or tap right for another video
you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!